Android TV gives you the tools to easily
extend your existing app or game, or
create new ones just for the big screen.
The most important thing to
remember here is that it's android.
It's the same platform you already
used to build your phone apps.
In fact, most of that code can
be used for the TV app as well.
It can even be in the same APK.
Here are the differences.
First, you've got to
declare the activity that's
intended to run on the TV.
This is done on the manifest.
Second, you want to update your UI
to use the Leanback Support Library.
It is not strictly required, and if you
like making things hard on yourself,
then don't use it.
For the rest of us, interface
widgets such as BrowseFragment,
DetailsFragment, and SearchFragment make
building a great TV UI fast and easy.
The third and final step is to make your
app and content available to the user.
In the first step, you will have
declared the Leanback launcher
intent-filter so that your app shows
up in the apps row on the home screen.
To have it show up in
the games row instead,
you just need to set is game
to true in the manifest.
There's also the opportunity for
your content to appear in the
recommendations row or through search.
The recommendations row is an essential
feature of the home screen.
It gives users quick access to
dynamic and relevant content.
It's essentially a bunch of cards that
represent a system or App Action,
notification, activity,
or piece of media.
We'll show you a little later how
to get your content shown here.
Search is important too, because users
often have specific content in mind and
browsing for that content is usually not
the fastest or easiest way to find it.
However, you can add a search action
in your app, which you should do, but
why stop there?
We'll also show you how to get your
content in Android TV's global search
as well.
That's it, three major steps to
getting the great experience for
your content on Android TV.
Declare your activity, use the Leanback
library to make everything look and
feel as it should on the TV, and
then integrate with recommendations and
search.